die abgeordneten werden sich jetzt mit
transparenz regelungen für abgeordnete
beschäftigen das thema
abgeordnetenbestechung transparenz von
abgeordneten ist ja schon länger thema
auch gestern ging es hier im bundestag
um ein lobbyregister gesetz das thema
ist besonders im fokus seit dem bei
mehreren unionsabgeordneten es fälle gab
dass sie geschäfte mit corona masken
umgesetzt haben georg nüßlein und
nikolas löbel sind schon aus der partei
ausgetreten bei einigen anderen
politikern es noch streit war inwieweit
sie ihr mandat ausgenutzt haben und
deswegen gibt es nun hier auch mehrere
anträge und gesetzentwürfe von den
oppositionsparteien die sich mit der
geschäftsordnung des deutschen
bundestages beschäftigen und die
nebentätigkeiten von abgeordneten
stärker kontrolliert haben möchten auch
bei den koalitionsparteien gibt es noch
redebedarf auch wenn es eben dieses
lobbyregister gesetzt jetzt auf den weg
gebracht wurde gibt es zwischen union
und spd doch unstimmigkeiten inwieweit
zum beispiel klar gemacht werden muss
wenn sich lobbyisten in
bundesministerien mit mitarbeitern dort
treffen patrick schnieder spricht jetzt
für die unionsfraktion
[Musik]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren mitglied dieses hohen
hauses zu sein ist er und verpflichtung
zugleich
wer dieses mandat ausüben darf muss sich
dabei allein am nutzen für das
gemeinwohl orientieren haltung anstand
und integrität sind unverzichtbare
voraussetzungen für die tätigkeit als
bundestagsabgeordneter eine tätigkeit im
übrigen auch das muss man an dieser
stelle sagen die angemessen und vor
allem ausreichend bezahlt ist für die
ganz überwältigende mehrheit der
kolleginnen und kollegen der unions
fraktion kann ich sagen dass sie diesen
anspruch lebt und sich tagtäglich mit
viel einsatz im besten sinne für das
wohl unseres landes engagiert zur
wahrheit gehört aber auch dass einige
frühere mitglieder unserer fraktion
diesem anspruch nicht gerecht geworden
sind und das vertrauen der wählerinnen
und wähler in sie gesetzt haben schwer
enttäuscht dass die menschen in unserem
land darüber empört sind kann ich gut
nachvollziehen kann ihnen versichern mir
und den anderen mitglieder meiner
fraktion geht es genauso
und schlimm ist dass es auf alle opfer
auf die anständigen auf die politik
insgesamt auf die institution bundestag
insgesamt und deshalb sollte man das
fehlverhalten einzelner auch nicht als
systemisch da stellen wir allen unsere
demokratie nehmen dann noch mehr schaden
aber auch das gehört zur wahrheit ich
hätte mir das was jetzt bekannt geworden
ist beim besten willen nicht und nicht
in diesem ausmaß vorstellen können ich
habe eben beschrieben was ich von einem
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
erwartet
für mich ist das eigentlich
selbstverständlich und daher bedarf es
auch keiner gesetzlichen regelungen
dafür leider musste ich mich müssen wir
uns eines besseren belehren lassen
wir haben jedenfalls verstanden dass wir
ohne deutliche und klare
gesetzesverschärfungen nicht mehr
auskommt
es gilt jetzt diese dinge schnell und
entschieden anzugehen und zu lösen
daher haben wir als union früh das heißt
kurz nach bekanntwerden der ersten fälle
eine transparenzoffensive beschlossen
und die koalition hat sich wie sie
vielleicht schon den medien entnehmen
konnten auf dieser grundlage auf einen
gemeinsamen maßnahmenkatalog verständigt
den wir jetzt zeitnah in einen
gemeinsamen gesetzentwurf wissen wollen
was ist unser maßstab erstens
transparenz ist kein selbstzweck es geht
darum mögliche interessenkonflikte bei
tätigkeiten von abgeordneten
offenzulegen bzw auszuschließen
allerdings sind dabei die freiheit des
mandates und die berufsfreiheit so
artikel 38 und 12 grundgesetz zu
beachten
und zweitens wenn es einen politischen
gesellschaftlichen konsens gibt dass
eine bestimmte art von geschäft der
abgeordneten per se unmoralisch und mit
blick auf damit verbundenen
interessenkonflikte gefährlich ist ist
es nur logisch und konsequent
diese auch gesetzlich zu verbieten und
verstöße hart zu sanktionieren müssen
aber aufpassen dass wir nicht das kind
mit dem bade ausschütten
die union ist stolz darauf dass
freiberufler unternehmer ärzte landwirte
handwerker im bundestag und in unseren
reihen dabei sind wir nicht wollen ist
ein reines beamten parlament oder nur
noch politiker die aus dem hörsaal
vielleicht über den umweg der mitarbeit
bei einem abgeordneten dann im
plenarsaal planten
worauf haben wir uns konkret verständigt
mit der spd wir wollen in zukunft
anzeigepflichtige einkünfte aus
nebentätigkeiten
unternehmensbeteiligungen betrags genau
auf euro und cent veröffentlichen
einkünfte sind nicht anzuzeigen wenn sie
im monat unter 1000 euro beziehungsweise
in der jahressumme und
3000 euro liegen beteiligungen war bei
aktiengesellschaften beteiligung an
sonstigen gesellschaften sollen ab 5
prozent angezeigt und veröffentlicht
werden ebenfalls einkünfte aus
anzeigepflichtigen
unternehmensbeteiligungen zum beispiel
dividenden und gewinnausschüttungen
sollen ebenfalls anzeige
veröffentlichungspflichtig werden auch
aktienoptionen unterfallen der anzeige
und veröffentlichungspflicht und zwar
unabhängig von der frage ob sie einen
bezifferbaren wert haben das soll auch
für vergleichbare finanzinstrumente
gelten
ein zentraler punkt bezogen vor allem
auf die inkriminierten fälle wenn ich so
sagen darf bezahlte lobbytätigkeit von
abgeordneten für tritte gegenüber
bundesregierung oder im bundestag soll
gesetzlich verboten werden
uns ist klar dass wir im einzelfall dort
noch genaue abgrenzung arbeit zu leisten
haben dafür ihre tätigkeit zum
ehrenamtlichen bereich gegen
aufwandsentschädigung dort nicht
grundsätzlich aus nehmen der missbrauch
der mitgliedschaft im deutschen
bundestag zu geschäftlichen zwecken ist
heute schon unzulässig wir wollen das
aber gesetzlich verbieten und mit
sanktionen versehen auch honorare für
reden und vorträge von abgeordneten
sollen verboten werden dass eine
kerntätigkeit die mit dem mandat
verbunden ist die wir keine zusätzliche
bezahlung regierung erwarten könnten
und schließlich wollen wir die
möglichkeit der abschöpfung verbotener
einnahmen schaffen wollen wir aus
unzulässigen geschäften einnahmen hat
muss diese abführen können zudem mit
einem zusätzlichen ordnungsgeld
verhängen werden schließlich wollen wir
den 108 e strafgesetzbuch verändern
hochstufungen zum verbrechen ist das
stichwort und die entgegennahme von
geldspenden durch abgeordnete soll in
zukunft verboten werden meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
an die opposition gerichtet will ich
sagen wir sehen unsere vorschläge gehen
nochmal über das hinaus was sie
vorgelegt haben
wir werden unsere vorschläge in der
koalition jetzt zügig umsetzen und einen
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf erarbeiten
gerade alle demokratischen fraktionen
ausdrücklich ein sich daran dann
konstruktiv zu beteiligen wir sind für
gespräche immer offen ich denke unsere
vorschläge innerhalb der koalition sind
die richtige antwort auf die vorfälle
den letzten wochen bekannt geworden sind
sie können dazu beitragen verloren
gegangenes vertrauen zurückzugewinnen
und für die zukunft sicherzustellen dass
so etwas möglich ist nicht mehr passiert
[Applaus]
thomas seidl wird als nächstes für die
af der sprecher für wahlprüfung
immunität und geschäftsordnung seiner
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ich bin
sehr angetan gewesen von den
ausführungen des kollegen aber ich will
dass erst mal schwarz auf weiß sehen und
abwarten ob nicht wie gestern beim lobby
gesetz nach eine regelung kommt die mehr
verdunkelt als erhält meine damen und
herren meine gestrige warnung vor der
kripo im plenarsaal erfolgte nicht ohne
grund
im verfahren ging mdb nüßlein und mdl
sauter er ging der erste haftbefehl zwar
nur gegen ein geschäftspartner aber die
einschläge kommen näher ist wohl nur
eine frage der zeit bis der erste
haftbefehl gegen ein mitglied des hohen
hauses folgt anträge für strengere
regeln werden so was in der
vergangenheit durch die bank abgelehnt
durch die regierungsbank aber warum
eigentlich
können sie das den redlichen
abgeordneten in ihren reihen überhaupt
erklären leider scheint geben salih ab
kann man den zug schrumpfen
zuletzt wurde über den cdu abgeordneten
joachim pfeiffer verstörende
einzelheiten berichtet so sei es ein
wahlkreisbüro auf telefonzentrale für
zwei der drei von ihm neben dem mandat
gegründeten unternehmen und bessere er
sein tageshoch von 3000 euro netto mit
der untervermietung seines
wahlkreisbüros auf angesichts der
jüngsten ereignisse bin ich einfach
schockiert und ich bin zornig schockiert
dass das aus stahl noch viel schlimmer
ist als ich mir je träumen ließ und
zornig walter bürger dieses gebaren seit
jahren ohnmächtig beobachten muss
jetzt auch zu drei wesentlichen
gesichtspunkten der heute der mattierten
anträge erstens bei der öffentlichen der
nebeneinkünfte ist es nicht entscheidend
dass diese auf den cent genau angegeben
werden
ich hätte kein problem damit 0 ist nun
egal wie veröffentlicht wird aber
notwendig ist es nicht aber die stufen
regelung in den verhaltensregeln ist im
grunde sinnvoll
nur müsste ab stufe 7 unbedingt
nachgebessert werden und
selbstverständlich höhere transparenz
nicht bei 250.000 euro auf wie es bisher
der union genügt hat das sind wir den
bürgern schuldig zweitens wieder
lobbytätigkeit von abgeordneten muss
schluss sein
jeder muss sich entscheiden ob er sich
als mit maul verdingen oder ob er
vertreter unseres volkes sein will
beides geht nicht drittens aktienoption
als entgelt für tätigkeit von
abgeordneten müssen verboten und das
halten von optionen
veröffentlichungspflichtig werden warum
anders als bei einem fixen geldbetrag
steht da wert von option nicht exakt
fest und kann beeinflusst werden
als ich anlässlich der affäre um für den
am tor das thema option in der
rechtsstellungskommission angesprochen
habe hat der verstorbene vizepräsident
thomas oppermann der kunden unions these
was damals noch vertreten wurde das
option ja gar kein wert hätten zu recht
heftig widersprochen und gerade optionen
wegen der gefahr des damit verbundenen
moral hazard als besonders problematisch
bezeichnet auch das halten von optionen
im rahmen der privaten
vermögensverwaltung ist nicht
unproblematisch da aufgrund der
hebelwirkung eine beeinflussung des
kurses hoch lukrativ ist und nicht
wieder normalen renditeerwartung von
wertpapieren im verhältnis zum
eingesetzten kapital vergleichbar ist
der bürger hat deshalb ein recht zu
wissen welcher abgeordnete
aktienoptionen auf hersteller von
windkraftanlagen erworben hat
abschließend noch eine anmerkung sie
können es sich sparen so wie gestern zur
ablenkung fehler mit spenden bei der afg
zu zitieren eine falsche behandlung von
sachspenden ist der unerfahrenheit einer
partei geschuldet gewesen und nicht im
ansatz mit geld vorfand von
waffenhändlern zu vergleichen
oder was meint herr schäuble dazu und
die dubiosen überweisungen aus der
schweiz betreffen ein laufendes
verfahren sollte sich gerichtlich
bestätigen dass es sich um eine
unzulässige parteispende gehandelt hat
habe ich keine zweifel dass die
verantwortlichen die notwendigen
konsequenzen ziehen das ist für die afg
als rechtsstaatspartei
selbstverständlich vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
derzeit setzen sie mit maske auf das
wort hat der kollege carsten schneider
für die spd carsten schneider ist
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
spd fraktion
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen haben
gestern abend gegen 22 uhr hier nach
langer beratung im bundestag das
lobbyregister beschlossen
es gilt den nächsten tagen dass wir in
deutschland gegenüber blockiert
gegenüber der bundestag und auch der
bundesregierung einfluss nimmt das
offenlegen
diese form der transparenz ist
entscheidend um vertrauen in die
demokratie zu erhalten und in teilen
zurück zu gewinnen
und heute
heute kommen wir zum zweiten punkt
aufgrund der ist eines antrags der
linksfraktionen debattieren über die
frage von uns selbst als abgeordnete und
die frage was steht im mittelpunkt
unseres mandats was sind die
möglicherweise nebentätigkeiten die ist
von kolleginnen kollegen aus
unterschiedlichen gründen gibt und gibt
es darüber transparent wir hätten uns
als spd fraktion vorstellen können
dieses transparent zu machen schon sehr
viel früher zu einigen und auch im
bundestag vorzulegen das war bisher mit
der unionsfraktion nicht möglich ich
bedauere sehr dass das erst jetzt
gelingt aber ich habe die rede herr
kollege china gehört aber die kollegen
kollegen auch sehr ernst genommen und
ich will dafür auch grundsätzlich meinen
respekt zollen dass sie sich als
fraktion sehr eindeutigen schnell
entschlossen haben sie von den kollegen
kollegen zu trennen die gruppe waren
wahrscheinlich oder die in einer manier
mit der krise geschäfte gemacht haben
wie es moralisch nicht unanständig ist
von daher bin ich nur sagen gut dass das
jetzt gelingt gut dass wir einen schritt
gehen können und ich bestätige heimlich
die einigung die sie eben genannt haben
zu den fragen der transparenz der
offenlegung von nebentätigkeiten ich
finde dass man das will ich klar sagen
dass abgeordnete große ehre hier sein zu
dürfen
ich habe das immer mit meinen wahlkreis
erfurt und weimar hier vertreten zu
dürfen ist eine große ehre aber auch
respekt begegnet ich habe immer
verteidigt dass wir hier unabhängig
unabhängigkeit sichernde bezahlung
bekommen nämlich 120.000 euro im jahr
brutto als diät also sehr viel geld zehn
prozent das mit gehört zu den top zehn
prozent der verdiener in deutschland
muss man wissen
und dann finde ich ist es auch nur
angemessen wenn die bevölkerung auch
klar weiß erstes das mandat steht im
mittelpunkt und zweitens das niemanden
sonst noch einfluss auf den oder die
abgeordneten
das gehört zusammen und aus diesem
grunde ja wir haben uns geeinigt wir
werden in der nächsten sitzungswoche
einen gesetzentwurf vorlegen der das
abgeordnetengesetz neu strukturiert ist
verschiedenen regeln die wir haben diese
unterschiedliche da sind unter einen hut
bringt es transparenter macht wir werden
eine kleine grenze haben von 1000 euro
im monat oder 3000 euro im jahr
wo man den den auftraggeber quasi
angeben muss auch ansonsten wird die
forderung die wir von anfang an hat
nämlich auf heller und cent offen zu
legen wir herrn nebeneinkünfte kommen
deutlich gemacht das ist wichtig und
dafür glaube ich danke ich und ich
glaube werden dafür auch eine mehrheit
hier eine große mehrheit im hause haben
von daher auch die punkte einer
möglichen unternehmensbeteiligung kommen
aus thüringen der fall des abgeordneten
hauptmann ehemaligen abbauen gibt durch
die republik mit entsetzen zu sehen wie
wie schamlos der krise verdient hat und
das geht nur über die beteiligung an
einem unternehmen war er hatte die
ehrenerklärung der union auch
unterschrieben in der fraktion
es ging nur darüber war das versprechen
das lager war erst in den gewinnen oder
nicht im gewinn des unternehmens wenn
sich ausgestellt wurde von daher ist für
uns entscheidend dass wir anzeigepflicht
weil ein abgeordneter in einem
unternehmen seien abgeordnete beteiligt
ist ab einer beteiligungsquote von 5%
deutlich gehört das sind 7 ag in eine
gmbh gbr ohg oder wo auch immer
beteiligt müssen sie es offen legen dass
auch ein schritt für transparenz die für
zwingend notwendig ist war auch sonst
über thesaurierung natürlich auch
gewinne verschleiert und auch erst nach
dem abrupten tätigkeit ausgezahlt werden
können das wollen wir nicht wir wollen
die verbot von lobbytätigkeit von
bundestagsabgeordnetem mandat wir wollen
die einstufung der
abgeordnetenbestechung als verbrechen
das sind alles notwendige schritte die
dazu führen die hoffentlich dazu führen
dass die verfehlungen einzelner der
verlorene moralische kompass einzelne
nicht auf das ganze haus abfärben
sondern das ganze haus letztendlich die
reputation sich wieder zurückholen kann
die durch abgeordnete unionsfraktion
mitleidenschaft gezogen wurde vielen
dank
carsten schneider hat hier den
abgeordneten ehemaligen abgeordneten aus
der cdu mag hauptmann angesprochen er
hat sein mandat hier schon in nieder
gelegt denn er steht im verdacht sich
von der regierung aserbaidschans für
politische dienste bezahlt zu haben
marco buschmann spricht jetzt für die
fdp auch er ist parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer seiner fraktion
präsidentin meine damen und herren
schwere verfehlungen hat es gegeben und
deshalb ist es gut dass wir die dinge
aufbereiten dass allerdings die afg im
zusammenhang mit straff anwalt mit
staatsanwaltschaftlichen
ermittlungsverfahren sich hier als
saubermänner gerieren das entbehrt doch
nicht einer gewissen komik denn wenn man
allgemein zugängliche quellen zu rate
zieht dann sind die einsamen
spitzenreiter bei den staatsanwaltlichen
ermittlungsverfahren ihre kollegen herr
seitz und das gehört auch zu ganzen war
viele kolleginnen und kollegen die vor
mir gesprochen haben haben zu allen
möglichen gesprochen nur nicht zu dem
antrag der uns vorliegt deshalb erlaube
ich mir auch zu kurz etwas zu sagen zu
dem antrag der uns vorliegen sollte die
fraktion die linke hat einen
gesetzentwurf erstellt und man muss
diesen gesetzentwurf nicht in jedem
punkt zustimmen
man kann ihn sogar ablehnen aber wenn
man hier über transparenz spricht dann
hätte die öffentlichkeit die transparenz
darüber verdient wie man in der sache
steht diesen gesetzentwurf intransparent
zu versenken wird im transparenz
anspruch nicht gerecht
damit nicht zu viel harmonie zwischen
fdp und linke aufgaben will ich zum
antrag in der sache hier eines sagen
dass der bundestagspräsident ohne
ausnahme demnächst dafür sorgen soll
dass beispielsweise auch anwälte die
branchen- ihrer mandanten geben soll ist
vermutlich in 90 vielleicht sogar in 99
prozent der fälle auch in ordnung da
finde ich es auch da kann man das machen
aber sie erinnern sich vom
bundesverfassungsgericht sind genau
diejenigen fälle verhandelt worden wo
bestimmte branchen die oligopol oder
monopol artig strukturiert sind wo die
branchenangaben im prinzip des mandats
geheimnis aufhebt und deshalb wäre
beispielsweise eine soll regelung besser
gewesen als eine muss regelung und
deshalb lehnen wir ihr anliegen ab das
anliegen im kern ist gut man muss es
aber handwerklich besser machen meine
sehr geehrten damen
wir haben in diesem haus auch einen
eigenen gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der
eines der vielen probleme hier angeht
das ist verschiedentlich angesprochen
worden das thema der aktienoptionen und
was die aktienoptionen angeht gibt es ja
gott sei dank auch einigkeit denn in der
tat ist die option verführerischer als
ein fixer geldbetrag
wir sollten aber nicht nur punktuell
die probleme die jetzt aufgetaucht sind
lösen sondern wir sollten das gesamte
problemgebiet lösen
es gibt nicht nur aktien optionen es
gibt auch andere sogenannte
finanzderivate die sogenannte
intensivieren würden die fachleute sagen
also anreizmechanismen auslösen und
deshalb haben wir ihn ein gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt der nicht nur die
aktienoptionen regelt sondern auch
andere derivate wie futures kontrakte
wir lösen das problem umfassend und
nicht nur punktuell und ich werbe um
zustimmung deshalb für unseren gesetzen
was das gesamtthema angeht ist hier
schon viel kluges und richtiges gesagt
worden es ist unerträglich wenn einige
hier manchmal sogar ohne beruf und ohne
geschäft in den bundestag kommen und
daraus politisch durch mit politischen
zugang oder durch die gewährung
politischen zugangs daraus einen beruf
oder ein geschäft machen wollen um ihr
mandat zu versilbern
das ist heute schon ein verstoß gegen
die verhaltenspflichten und wenn das
nicht ausreicht finde ich es auch
richtig die regeln zu verschärfen und
auch zu sanktionieren solche kollegen
schaden dem ansehen des deutschen
bundestages
wir müssen aber am ende auch auf eines
aufpassen es gibt genau so und das ist
die große vielzahl kollegen die
selbstständige handwerksmeister sind ja
eine freiberufler praxis haben die
unternehmer sind die sich vor dem einzug
in den bundestag anständig und legal
einen eigenen geschäftsbetrieb aufgebaut
haben und ich will in erinnerung rufen
die durchschnittliche verweildauer des
abgeordneten in diesem haus beträgt acht
jahre
einige glauben ja sei irgendwie
erstrebenswert hier erst im
pensionsalter rauszugehen aber die
wahrheit ist die durchschnittliche
verweildauer beträgt acht jahre
nach diesen acht jahren kehrt der beamte
auf seinen alten dienstposten zurück und
das ist auch richtig und gut so nach
diesen acht jahren kehrt der angestellte
in seine alte position zurück das ist
richtig und gut so und deshalb muss auch
der anständige selbständige der
anständige handwerksmeister der
anständige unternehmer eine möglichkeit
haben nach acht jahren in seinen
aufgebauten geschäftsbetrieb
zurückzukehren und deshalb muss er die
möglichkeit haben ihm auch am leben zu
halten meine damen und herren wir haben
nicht zu viel unternehmerischen
sachverstand in diesem haus wir haben zu
wenig und deshalb verbitte ich mir jede
pauschale diskriminierung und
inkriminiert unserer kollegen die einen
anständigen geschäftsbetrieb aufgebaut
haben diese kollegen stellen übrigens in
ihrer ganz großen mehrheit das mandat
auch in ihren mittelpunkt ich habe das
in alten fraktionen erlebte ich erlebe
dass jetzt ein ehemaliger kollege von
mir war bäckermeister der hat einen
anderen bäckermeister angestellt da
blieb am ende des jahres nicht viel
übrig aber diese angestellte
bäckermeister hat den betrieb am leben
erhalten und hat dafür gesorgt dass die
angestellten auch einen job hatten und
der kollege hat sich ganz dem mandat
gewidmet das erkennt man an den neben 1
nicht weil zur belohnung darf der
kollege die umsätze an geben und ich
finde das ist in ordnung aber wir
sollten aufhören mit dem finger auf die
bloßen umsätze zu zeigen und daraus
einen rückschluss auf den anstand der
kolleginnen und kollegen zu ziehen er
sei rein betreibt der gehört
angeprangert aber nicht pauschal und
deshalb meine damen und herren es gibt
ja nicht nur dieses beispiel die
kollegen der union haben viel prügel
eingesteckt ich will mal ein lobendes
beispiel bringt der kollege marion wendt
der ist er ist präsident der
bundesvereinigung des thw und ich finde
es gut dass es ich will nicht dass sich
das parlament von der gesellschaft
entkoppelt dieser kollege hat in der
fragestunde der bundeskanzlerin fragen
die auch den thw treffen bestellt
gestellt das kann man als lobbyismus
bezeichnen aber er hat transparent vor
aller öffentlichkeit gemacht und ich
finde wir müssen bei allen regeln die
jetzt notwendig sind aufpassen dass wir
nicht das ehrenamt und die
selbständigkeit ist systematisch aus
diesem parlament vertreiben das
jedenfalls es mit den freien demokraten
nicht zu machen
das wort hat der kollege jan korte für
die fraktion die ligen kollege muss man
präsidenten kollege buschmann
vielen dank ja in der tat wie heute was
vorgelegt hat auch sie natürlich ein
mach mit mach's nach mach's besser dass
wir hier noch was besseres handwerklich
hinbekommen aber immerhin antwortet was
vorgelegt wo dass wir entscheiden können
ich möchte nun etwas grundsätzliches
sagen zu der situation in der wir über
diese fragen diskutieren denn das ist ja
das entscheidende warum es auch solche
wellen in der öffentlichkeit schlägt und
man muss eine ordnung was
gesellschaftspolitisch gerade in diesem
land passiert auf der einen seite mit
corona bedingt das impf desaster test
desaster um persönlich schwerste
einschränkungen die die menschen in kauf
nehmen und den kauf nehmen müssen und
ein völliges chaos im übrigen in der
bundesregierung dass die eine seite die
leute waren auf der anderen seite nehmen
sie im selben zeitraum war dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister auf einem
spenden dingen abhängt und dort zufällig
alle gäste 9.999 euro an seinen
kreisverband spenden
das stimmt wirklich der kompass
vollständig nicht und während und werden
pflegekräfte ärzte passieren und
passiere im wahrsten sinne des worte
sich krumm machen jeden tag und nicht
wissen wie sie durch den monat kommen wo
menschen in kurzarbeit sind gibt es dann
einige abgeordnete insbesondere die cdu
zwischen muss hier noch mal auffällig
geworden die sich die taschen
vollstopfen ohne ende
hauptmann löbel nüsslein weiter ich habe
jetzt eben gelesen dass ja auch der
ehemalige kollege peter gauweiler sich
noch nebenbei ein kleines taschengeld
dazu verdient hat wird er abgeordneter
gewesen ist und das kriegen die damit
ist und wahrscheinlich alles nur
einzelfälle
ich glaube mittlerweile nicht mehr daran
und das müssen sie überlegen wie wirkt
das auf
diese menschen wie wirkt das auf diese
menschen an ihren dieser situation und
deswegen kann man sich keinen schlanken
fuß machen zu sagen jetzt ändern wir mal
irgendwas seit jahren seit
legislaturperiode um legislaturperiode
werden hier diese dinge vorgeschlagen
und es ist immer wieder an ihnen
gescheitert
das ist die wahrheit und das motto
ausgesprochen der überbelegung kollegen
und vielleicht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der csu muss man ja auch mal
wenn man dafür vielleicht gar kein
gespür hat für diese wirtschaftlichen
verquickung für diese unmengen an pole
die dort fließt für normale menschen
überhaupt gar nicht vorstellbar um was
für beträge es geht vielleicht einfach
mal darüber nachdenken in was für einer
umgebung sie sich eigentlich so
aufhalten
das scheint wirklich abzusehen dass
diese politik
deswegen will ich nicht auf irgendwelche
positionspapiere kommen die jetzt hier
grad carsten genossen schneider
großartig vorgetragen worden ist das
kennen wir immer wenn wieder irgendetwas
gewesen ist ich glaube erst daran wenn
hier etwas schwarz auf weiß vorliegt
kollegin hasselmann hat das letztlich
deutlich gesagt geschwitzt wurde benutzt
dann legt jetzt auch endlich fast vor
wir haben heute etwas vorgelegt nämlich
einen antrag dem können sie heute
zustimmen da können sie sich diese
ganzen komischen runden abend 20 uhr
sparen indem wir einfach zustimmen weil
es ist ja offensichtlich ihre intention
wie auch kollege schneider hier
vorgetragen hat genau das nicht heute
zur abstimmung namentlich vornehmlich
die nebeneinkünfte auf euro und cent
auszuweisen und vor allem
branchenangaben einzuführen das können
wir heute hier beschließen
sparen sie sich zeit und her
und vor ostern wäre das das richtige
signal an die bürgerinnen und bürger in
dem sich das nochmal gegenüber stellen
damit man einfach mal versteht wie etwas
wird dass wir nicht nämlich schon eine
ganz zentrale frage von jedem
hartz-iv-empfänger erwartet man und
setzt es durch das ja alles offen licht
der berliner zeitung war dazu ein
wirklich gutes zitat ich möchte einmal
vortragen damit man sieht worüber wir
reden von denen die am wenigsten haben
wird aus gründen der kontrollierbarkeit
die größtmögliche transparenz verlangt
während man denjenigen die das volk im
parlament vertreten offenbar zutraut mit
nebeneinkünften verantwortungsvoll
umzugehen
die erfahrung der letzten wochen zeigt
es ist vielmehr umgekehrt
das ist der kern um den es hier geht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und das
sind würden wir heute hier und jetzt
will ich noch mal eins sagen das hat
fairness halber der kollege buschmann
hier mal angesprochen ich will da schon
noch mal sagen
damit sie hier nicht glauben dass sie
hier einfach so raus kommen er wird ein
großes blaues auge wird bei ihnen
verbleiben will das schon mal deutlich
sagen wir haben vor wochen als
linksfraktion ein gesetzentwurf
eingebracht in den deutschen bundestag
bezahlte lobbytätigkeit von abgeordneten
schlicht zu verbieten einen eigenen
gesetzentwurf seit wochen nicht mehr im
parlament
und sie haben in den letzten beiden
sitzungswochen kollege sensburg haben
wir darum gebeten endlich eine
beschlussempfehlung im
geschäftsordnungsausschuss und im
rechtsausschuss zu bekommen damit wir
hätten heute
wir hätten sogar letzte woche schon
darüber entscheiden können die sind
jetzt offenbar dafür und zweimal und das
müssen die bürgerinnen und bürger wissen
damit man das einordnen kann was hier an
reden gehalten wird zwei mal und mit
hilfe der spd ist besonders bitter
übrigens besonders bitter wurde es von
der tagesordnung des geschäfts
ordnungsausschusses gestimmt und zwar
nur aus einem grund damit wir es hier
heute nicht entscheiden können das ist
das allerletzte
das ist schäbig und
so geht deswegen das treffen die ihnen
auch nicht mit kind liebe kollegen und
politik deswegen haben sich finde ich
eine große chance vertan dass wir hier
sozusagen eine kleine hilfestellung
ihnen heute gegeben hätten wo wir
gemeinsam was machen können ich habe im
übrigen vor zwei wochen an ihre fraktion
an alle fraktionen an brief geschrieben
ob wir uns mich interfraktionell einigen
könnten weil ich weiß dass sie sehr
ideologisch sind und grundsätzlich
selbst den klügsten anträgen der linken
nicht zustimmen können weil die linke
darauf steht ich habe einen brief an sie
geschrieben an die spd und die cdu csu
und gesagt wir wären bereit unseren
antrag weil sie damit ideologische
probleme haben also mit dem einreicher
zurückzuziehen
zugunsten einer gemeinsamen regelung die
wir hätten heute hier beschließen können
ich habe von ihnen beiden nicht mal eine
antwort bekommen das ist so schlechter
stil und dafür höfliche menschen sind
kollegen nieder
sie habe neben uns eingeladen die
demokratischen fraktionen dass wir
gemeinsam etwas machen können wir nehmen
die einladung sehr gerne an und werden
dort konstruktiv mitarbeiten
mal gucken ob es wieder logisch ist oder
was ist geblieben sind
jan korte war das für die linksfraktion
auf die nächste rednerin ins
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
britta haßelmann und diese funktion für
die grünen-fraktion hier im bundestag
aus sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ich knüpfe gleich da an
auch wir haben der fraktion der spd der
fraktion der cdu/csu der fraktion der
fdp und der linken geschrieben die
generalsekretäre angeschrieben und die
ersten parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
schon vorletzte woche nach bekanntwerden
der ersten skandale und darum gebeten
dass wir gemeinsam im parlament weil es
eine so tiefe vertrauenskrise ist die
entstanden ist durch diese bestechung
durch diese korruption durch diese
geschäftemacher einzelne die hat das
ganze parlament getroffen und deshalb
haben wir sie angeschrieben genau wie
die linken wir haben von ihnen noch
nicht meine antwort erhalten meine damen
und herren
so ist die lage und dann heute mit
großer geste zu sagen wir laden sie alle
ein wir haben auch noch kurz vor der
debatte gerade noch das eckpunktepapier
der tagesschau lanciert ich hätte
anderes erwartet meine damen und herren
nachgeben gesprächsangebot was wir
am dienstag in der geschäftsführer runde
haben wir noch mal investiert nochmal
gefragt sollte nicht reden
naja der kollege schneider hat nach
dreimaligem auffordern dann auch
beantwortet herr große brömer hat uns
erklärt nein nein reden jetzt mit ihnen
auf keinen fall wir machen erstmal in
der koalition dann irgendwann kommen wir
auf sie zu sosie zusammenarbeit aus man
den damen und herren ich habe eine
andere vorstellung vor allen dingen in
einer solch kritischen frage wozu thema
meine damen und herren weiter in der
sache
nüßlein löbel hauptmann sauter allesamt
von der cdu/csu bereichern sich
persönlich in der maske affäre und
bestreiten geschäftemacherei in und
durch die korona krise während
gleichzeitig so viele menschen
unternehmen familien und kinder unter
der pandemie leiden das ist zutiefst
unanständig und das spüren die menschen
das ist schäbig meine damen und herren
linder von der csu
axel fischer tobias sich allesamt in die
alpha-bank affäre verstrickt meine damen
und herren auch inzwischen wissen dass
die menschen die nehmen das wahr
das sind keine einzelfälle gauweiler bis
2015 csu bundestagsabgeordneter hat
während seiner zeit im bundestag in der
zeit von 2008 bis 2015 beraterhonorare
in höhe von elf millionen euro kassiert
es gab offenbar so die
presseberichterstattung regelmäßige
rechnung über vereinbarte
pauschalhonorar von oder an einen
gewissen herrn fink meine damen und
herren der name fink im übrigen wir uns
zuletzt unter kam im zusammenhang
mit den parteispenden sumpf der afg da
wird dein name finden genannt und jetzt
hier bei gauweiler wieder der name fink
im übrigen hat die afg aus meiner sicht
jede glaubwürdigkeit in dieser frage
längst verloren sie hat sie nie gehabt
meine damen und herren 500.000 euro
strafzahlungen haben die herren und
damen von der afg bisher bezahlt weitere
verfahren sind in prüfung also leute die
sich nicht an recht und gesetz halten
haben hier den parlament keine
ratschläge zu machen meine damen alfred
sauter csu auf innovativer strikt in die
masken affäre blickt auf eine 40-jährige
parteikarriere der csu
es reicht politik ihrer partei machen
sich den staat zur beute
mitten in der pandemie und es geht
längst nicht mehr nur um transparenz und
offenlegung von lobbyarbeit es geht um
das vertrauen in unsere demokratie und
auf um das ansehen von politik insgesamt
und es geht verdammt noch mal auch um
anstand
hören sie endlich auf meine herren und
damen von der cdu/csu von einzelfällen
zu reden
das wäre der erste anknüpfungspunkt für
besserung das wäre der erste
anknüpfungspunkt für änderung die cdu
csu hat ein strukturelles problem und
das wissen sie sind ganz genau
die vergangenheit und ein blick in die
gegenwart macht das deutlich schwarze
kassen amigo affäre verwandten
scheinselbstständigen affäre an affäre
aserbaidschan connection masken
geschäftemacherei vorwürfe zu bestechung
korruption und bereicherung stehen im
raum
politische landschaftspflege als alltags
modell und vetternwirtschaft das ist ein
strukturelles problem das hat fürs team
und das haben sie geduldet sie haben es
mindestens gebäude
sie haben ein massives problem in der
frage des verhältnisses von
wirtschaftlicher macht geld einfluss und
sauberer politik und dem gemeinwohl und
das müssen sie erkennen warum haben sie
denn die letzten jahre geschwiegen
sie wussten doch dass es solche
situationen gibt wie abgeordnete wie der
kollege pfeiffer mit 15 nebenjobs und
mehr
da kann man doch nicht sagen es geht um
berufstätigkeit einzelne und da sind sie
auch dafür niemand muss im öffentlichen
dienst gewesen sein sondern wie
vielleicht in seinem beruf zurückkehren
hören sie doch auf mit der geschichte
bei 15 jedem einzelfall mehr
meine damen und herren oder die
beratungshonorare von herrn ramsauer
500.000 euro beratungshonorar in sie das
normal
nein ich finde das nicht normal dass man
neben seinem abgeordnetenmandat was sie
mittelpunkt der tätigkeit steht so viel
geld verdient hier im kino
wir können weitermachen und auch beim
radeln letzte legislaturperiode
bei über der hälfte der namentlichen
abstimmung nicht da hat sie das
interessiert aber dass mein thema in
ihrer fraktion tun sie doch bitte nicht
so als seien das jetzt einzelne die
ausgetreten wären aus ihrer partei
sie haben da ein problem und wir
brauchen jetzt dringend nicht einen
freiwilligen verhaltenskodex nicht eine
ehrenerklärung dass sie es ja daran dass
ihr hauptmann die auch unterschrieben
hat ja der hat vor zwei wochen noch
william regierung unterschrieben wir
brauchen jetzt konkrete initiativen
entgeltliche lobbyarbeit muss endlich
gestoppt werden und viele weitere punkte
zur verschärfung der
parteienfinanzierung wir haben dazu
heute einen antrag vorgelegt wir sind
die kollegen herausgeholt mehrheit sie
müssen zum schluss kommen fraktionen wir
haben sofort abstimmung einen antrag
hier liegen der enthält sämtliche
forderungen zu transparenz und
veröffentlichung bitte bis zur
abstimmung durften heute lesen werden
aber nicht mehr vorgetragen unter wasser
mann war das hat jedoch ein bisschen
ihrer redezeit überzogen wurde
allerdings von bundestags
vizepräsidentin petra pau nur darauf
hingewiesen auf britta haßelmann folgt
jetzt volker ullrich erst der
rechtspolitische sprecher der csu
fraktion auch in der csu gab es ja der
csu landesgruppe pardon auch in der csu
gab es ja fälle von möglichen
machtmissbrauch sehr verehrten damen und
herren es gibt nichts zu beschönigen es
ist eine schwierige situation
ich verstehe die wut und die empörung
vieler menschen über grobes
fehlverhalten und ist es richtig und
angemessen dass die betroffenen kollegen
konsequenzen gezogen haben um bei denen
wo die konsequenzen noch nicht
hinreichend bestimmt genug sind also
mandatsniederlegung und parteiaustritt
wollen wir dass diese konsequenzen auch
noch an den tag gelegt werden
wer in eine notsituation sich persönlich
bereichert handelt ohne anstand und ist
dieses bundestages unwürdig im interesse
der parlamentarischen demokratie
insgesamt bin ich aber auch dass es
keinen generalverdacht und keine
mithaftung gibt das fehlverhalten
mancher darf nicht zum vertrauensverlust
alle führen in jeder fraktion gibt es
kolleginnen und kollegen die mit großem
einsatz und hohem persönlichen
commitment sich für das mandat im
wahlkreis und im bundestag einsetzen und
das muss betont werden weil wir nicht
wollen insgesamt dass durch diese
vorkommnisse vertraut die demokratie
zerstört wird
es ist wichtig dass jetzt konsequenzen
gezogen werden
ausgangslage ist das grundgesetz
abgeordnete sind nur ihrem gewissen
unterworfen
aber man muss eben auch vor seinem
eigenen gewissen sich prüfen wie stark
man sich für das mandat einsetzt
wer immer auch die ehre hat hier im
deutschen bundestag als abgeordneter
dienen zu dürfen und ich betone das wort
dienen
das soll das mit respekt und dankbarkeit
tun und nicht daran denken was er
nebenher verdienen kann sondern wie er
sich verdienste um die bevölkerung
erwerben kann meine nach unten
entscheidend ist dass das mandat absolut
im mittelpunkt steht und eine
vermischung des mandats mit eigenen
wirtschaftlichen interessen ist künftig
zu unterbinden
wir wollen und werden einen
gesetzentwurf vorlegen zum verbot
bezahlter interessenvertretung
nebentätigkeiten soll abgesehen von
einer paar kartell schwelle komplett auf
euro und cent angegeben werden
wir wollen diese transparenz das klar
und deutlich wird wer immer auch was
neben dem mandat hinzuverdienst muss
darüber rechenschaft ablegen vor dem
bundestag und vor der öffentlichkeit
durch krise transparenz stellen wir
vertrauen wieder her und es ist auch
nicht unzumutbar im europäischen
parlament und im europarat ist das
übrigens auch nach der aufarbeitung der
affäre mittlerweile gang und gäbe und es
ist richtig dass jeder sieht was ein
kollege sich dazu verdient klar ist aber
auch wir wollen nebentätigkeiten nicht
ganz verbieten weil wir ein parlament
sein wollen für alle wenn im deutschen
bundestag nur noch angehörige des
öffentlichen dienstes sitzen würden
die übrigens irgendwie der exekutive
zugeordnet sind
dann hätten wir abgeordnete die
mittelbar zur exekutive gehören die sie
am ende selbst kontrollieren wollen wir
wollen auch selbstständige haben ärzte
und handwerker die sich
selbstverständlich dann auch um das
mandat kümmern
aber wichtig ist eben auch dass wir kein
reines beamten und angestellten
parlament zählt sind eine vertretung des
gesamten deutschen volkes
entscheidend ist auch dass der über die
abgeordnetenbestechung sprechen und zwar
über den tatbestand und über die straff
rahmenhöhe ich meine es ist angemessen
dass wir deutlich machen wir einen
abgeordneten besticht begeht ein
verbrechen mindeststrafe ein jahr es
geht darum dass wir die integrität des
parlamentarischen verfahrens insgesamt
schützen
und wir müssen auch sprechen über den
tatbestand bei der beamtenbestechung
geht es nur darum dass man einen vorteil
annimmt das genügt bei den abgrund ist
es eine ungerechtfertigte vorteile
vielleicht kann man das angleichen so
dass die voraussetzungen wesentlich
schärfer werden
das alles wollen wir in einem
gesetzespaket vorstellen
und dahinter steckt eine klare erwartung
an uns selbst und an das parlament
wir wissen
um die vorfälle unsere pflicht das
aufzuarbeiten
wir werden aber auch deutlich machen auf
was es ankommt
respekt integrität und anstand würde des
hauses und vertraue demokratie das
werden wir noch ein kraftvolles paket
wiederherstellen und stärken weil klar
und deutlich wird es ist eine ehre im
deutschen bundestag die arbeiten zu
dürfen und das sollte man mit seiner
ganzen kraft tun vom ersten tag bis zum
letzten tag seines mandates herzlichen
dank volker uns war das für die unions
fraktion auf ihn folgt jetzt stefan
brandt nah er ist mitglied der afg
fraktion und sitzt im ausschuss für
recht und verbraucherschutz
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
korruption kommt heute meistens subtiler
daher als noch früher früher als 100000
mark im koffer
heute geht es anders heute bekommt man
lukrative einflussreiche posten oder
pöstchen für system system konformes
verhalten oder post politisches
schweigen die präsidentenstelle beim
bundesverfassungsgericht einen
vorstandsposten bei der deutschen bahn
man wird präsidentin einer bundesanstalt
dazu fallen 1 gleich die namen herbert
pofalla und nahles ein aber auch die
grünen pro hasselmann lassen sich nicht
lumpen und gerne einkaufen fliegender
wechsel zu lobbyverbänden von ihren
früheren vorsitzenden gunda röstel und
kerstin andreae die
hauptgeschäftsführerin wurde bei einem
bundesverband das gehört ebenso zum
guten grünen ton wie wechsel in die
süßwarenindustrie vom ehemaligen
staatssekretär berninger oder im bereich
der dämmstoff und zigarettenindustrie
wie die ehemalige staatssekretärin tritt
und wem ist bei einem lobby job nicht
reicht intellektuell oder mental und er
trotzdem viel geld braucht er borgt sich
viel geld bei dubiosen darlehensgebern
ich sage nur system ihren soweit die
vergangenheit nun hängt die korruption
meine damen und herren seit einigen
wochen die ein damoklesschwert über den
parteien
zuvörderst denen der cdu und csu später
sagen bereits das c stunde für klaren
kriminalität aber stimmt das sind am tor
niesslein sparen die familie nach steht
unsere der baum hole us autor uwe
fischer bargau weiler zweifach mit drei
f frau hohlmeier also die strauß-tochter
frau tandler die tochter des ehemaligen
bayerischen finanzministers herr
hauptmann aus dem engsten thüringer
mohring umfeld eher lindner herr caffier
der ihrem auf der straub herr rieger wie
sie alle heißen sind das tatsächlich nur
einzelfälle die ganz wie korruption zu
tun haben
ich tendiere zu der auffassung es sind
keine einzelfälle korruption und
bestechlichkeit sind typisch für ein
system in dem immer die gleichen
irgendwo irgendwo regiert
und an den schaltstellen der macht
sitzen jahrzehntelange immer gleiche
regierungsbeteiligung und wecken
interessen bei bestecken und
begehrlichkeiten auf der anderen seite
waren wir sehen an diesem geschichten
die maxime dem deutschen volke die
draußen am reichstag steht die gilt für
sie nicht mehr für sie gilt die maxime
wer wird millionär und das ist verdammt
ich das sage ich ihnen von hier vorne
aus interessant ist ja dass in diesem
system die ganzen korruptions findet
jetzt ja vor kam mit den jungspunden und
hinterbänklern aus cdu/csu da sind
millionenbeträge geflossen
ich persönlich würde mal interessieren
wie sieht es denn mit den leuten auch
die vorne sitzen die tatsächlich bei
ihnen einfluss haben gibt es da dann um
sechs oder siebenstellige summen damit
noch einiges zu tage kommen
ich bin überzeugt zum antrag selber um
diesen missständen beizukommen helfen
gesetzliche vorschriften nur bedingt und
ihren erklärungen ich sage nur hauptmann
helfen schon mal gar nicht gegen solche
auswüchse gegen kleptokraten wallungen
helfen nur ein grundlegender
politikwechsel und viele jahre der
altparteien in der opposition und daran
meine damen und herren arbeiten wir
dafür arbeiten wir jeden tag von hier
vorne und auf den straßen vielen dank
[Applaus]
matthias barth gemacht sich hier schon
bereit er sprecher für wahlprüfung
immunität und geschäftsordnung der
spd-fraktion frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen kollegen man muss es ja mal
aussprechen
die skandale in der cdu und vor allem in
der csu haben auch ihr gutes
die von der linken seite dieses hauses
immer schon erhobenen forderungen nach
mehr transparenz bei abgeordneten findet
nun endlich gehör
das ist das ist schön und traurig
zugleich es bedarf eben immer
irgendwelche skandale
wir haben das auch beim lobbyregister
gesehen die gespräche dümpelten erst so
vor sich hin erster fall amthor
beschleunigt ihr das ganze dann ungemein
und die masken affäre war dann ein
regelrechter toro verstärker für die
einigung
das gleiche gilt für die abgeordneten
transparent die spd hat hier vor zwei
wochen einen zehn punkte plan vorgelegt
daraufhin hat die cdu einen zehn punkte
plan vorgelegt und dann kam auch die csu
mit einem zehn punkte plan
das war ein richtiger
überbietungswettbewerb großartig
man isst man ist geneigt zu sagen es
geht doch
heute haben wir beschlossen heute habe
ich es geschlossen und die pläne werden
umgesetzt
die nachricht des tages ist man kann es
nicht oft genug wiederholen wir haben
uns bei der anzeigepflicht für
nebentätigkeiten geeinigt einkünfte aus
nebentätigkeiten unternehmensbeteiligung
müssen künftig beitrags genau auf euro
und cent veröffentlicht werden und zwar
und zwar dann wenn sie im monat den
betrag von 1000 euro oder wenn sie bei
ganzjährigen tätigkeiten die betrag von
insgesamt 3000 euro übersteigen also
januar februar märz april jeweils 1000
euro ist schon zuviel muss angezeigt
werden dass diese kollegen kollegen ist
eine geradezu revolutionäre
veränderungen die man gar nicht hoch
genug einschätzen kann
die nächste gravierende veränderung
unternehmensbeteiligung müssen künftig
ab 5 prozent der gesellschaftsanteile
veröffentlicht werden und zwar egal
dass sich um kapital oder um personen
gesellschaften handeln und ganz wichtig
auch die daraus resultierenden einkünfte
müssen angezeigt und veröffentlicht
werden und herr buschmann
sie haben recht einkünfte sind nicht
umsetze und die derzeitige regelung ist
nicht gut und das muss geändert werden
und das werden wir auch ändern
aktienoptionen werden künftig anzeige
uns veröffentlichungs
veröffentlichungspflichtig sein
das gilt unabhängig von der frage ob sie
einen bezifferbaren wert haben man sieht
der fall am tor hatte auch sein gutes
bezahlte la vie tätigkeiten vom
bundestagsabgeordneten gegenüber
bundesregierung oder bundestag werden
gesetzlich verboten
die fälle in denen abgeordnete ihre
mitgliedschaft künftig missbrauchen und
dadurch einnahmen erzielen wird es bald
nicht mehr geben denn diese einnahmen
müssen künftig eine bundestag abgeführt
werden
ach hätten wir diese regelung doch bloß
schon vorher gehabt den missbrauch der
mitgliedschaft im deutschen bundestag zu
geschäftlichen zwecken werden wir
gesetzlich verbieten
in dem zusammenhang wollen wir auch
honorare für vorträge untersagen da
fallen mir spontan mindestens zwei
abgeordnete ein deren geschäftsmodell
dadurch schwer ins wanken geraten dürfte
wir werden die mindeststrafe bei
abgeordnetenbestechung auf ein jahr
erhöhen abgeordnetenbestechung und
abgeordneten bestechlichkeit sind damit
ein verbrechen
manche abgeordnete haben bestechung der
in der vergangenheit ganz offenbar als
kavaliersdelikt angesehen
die zeiten sind nun endgültig vorbei wir
werden dabei schauen ob wir uns nicht
auch einmal den objektiven tatbestand
des § 108e strafgesetzbuch angucken wenn
er nämlich wirklich greifen soll dann
muss er ein schärferes schwert werden
und ich habe mich gefreut dass das in
der gestrigen debatte auch bei einigen
unions redner angeklungen ist lieber
herr korte sie werden es verstehen dass
wir ihrem antrag nicht zustimmen werden
es einfach es einfach nicht weitgehend
genug liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abschließend will ich sagen abschließend
bin ich sagen gestern das lobbyregister
heute die transparenz hinwirken regelung
ich finde das war eine richtig gute
woche ich dagegen matthias tatge war das
für die spd und auf ihn folgt jetzt
patrick sensburg er ist vorsitzender des
geschäftsordnungsausschuss es hier im
bundestag und er hat bereits anfang 2020
ein gesetzentwurf für ein lobbyregister
vorgelegt damals hatten sich einige
fraktionskollegen noch darüber gewundert
über diesen vorstoß mittlerweile ist da
ja wie wir wissen
der eindruck auch unter cdu csu kollegen
ein anderer sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist gut dass wir heute über
nebeneinkünfte einkünfte
verhaltensregeln ändern des
abgeordnetengesetzes und der
geschäftsordnung und die transparenz
reden und ich kann auch sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der fraktion
die linke verstehen dass sie das auf die
tagesordnung gesetzt haben wollen es ist
auch gut
es ist auch gut dass wir heute alle alle
fraktionen das kritisiert haben was als
verhalten in den letzten wochen völlig
inakzeptabel war da war konsens in
diesem haus und das ist gut so
es ist auch gut so dass die kollegen die
das gemacht haben die konsequenzen
gezogen haben und das war das richtige
zeichen dass wir das zwingende zeichen
und das ist auch gut so und ich würde
mir wünschen und meine damen und herren
von der fraktion der afg ich will gar
nicht auf ihre anträge und auf ihre
ausführung groß eingehen aber sie haben
ja pauschal über alle parteien alle
fraktionen grad die kritik ausgeschüttet
ich würde mir dann auch wünschen wenn
diese selbstkritik mal in der eigenen
fraktion ankommen würde
sie haben nämlich in vielen fällen auch
viele fehler gemacht und dann ist es
manchmal auch gut wenn man sich selbst
beim spiegel betrachtet und selbstkritik
geübt
es ist auch gut dass wir zeitnah und der
kollege barthle hat es gerade gesagt
dass wir zeitnah eine sehr umfassende
eine sehr detaillierte regelung bekommen
werden die noch über den antrag die
anträge der fraktion die linke und auch
der anderen fraktionen hinausgeht und
das ist zu begrüßen zwei mal herr
kollege konnte das ist völlig richtig
war es im geschäftsordnungsausschuss ist
allerdings nicht von der tagesordnung
gesetzt worden sondern vertagt worden
ein kleiner unterschied wir haben es
diskutiert der unterschied liegt darin
dass die koalition in der sitzung
mehrmals gesagt wer hat es wird
vorschläge geben bitte lassen sie uns
doch die vorschläge der koalition mit
einbeziehen und das ist glaube ich auch
wichtig dass man die dinge gemeinsam
diskutieren kollege sensburg gestatten
sie eine frage oder bemerkung des sehr
gerne
jan korte meldet sich noch mal zu wort
ja danke frau präsidentin danke dass sie
zwischen frage zu lassen also das will
ich jetzt schon normal von ihnen
detailliert hier dargestellt bekommen
haben wir haben man kann uns als
opposition gut finde oder blöd finden
das ist ja jedem unbenommen wir haben
unsere arbeit gemacht und vor wochen
einen gesetzentwurf eingebracht was zur
arbeit von parlamentariern und
fraktionen gehört und wir haben zweimal
darum gebeten diesen gesetzentwurf zu
diskutierenden
geschäftsordnungsausschuss und ihnen
dann hier abstimmen zu lassen
und jetzt will ich mal fragen das müssen
die leute das müssen wir denen jetzt
noch mal genau sagen ob sie das wirklich
so meint nur weil sie es nicht
hinbekommen
nur falls sie seit 20 30 jahren jungen
und ihre geschäftemacher schützen wollen
hindern sie die opposition an ihrer
arbeit ein gesetzentwurf ihr
einzubringen was unsere arbeit ist sie
verhindern also die arbeit und das
erklären sie doch jetzt mal alle
nur weil sie ankündigen vielleicht mal
irgendwann da vorzulegen sorgen sie
dafür dass es ein vorschlag den kann man
gut finden oder schlecht finden dass der
hier nicht abgestimmt werden kann
das ist wirklich durch und durch volle
kanne daneben das erklären
jeder familie korte das ist nicht voll
daneben
es ist gut es ist gut wenn mehrere
fraktionen vorschläge haben die
fraktions vorschläge auch gemeinsam
beraten und diskutieren zu können nicht
einen vorab zur abstimmung zu bringen
wir werden vielleicht expertenanhörungen
habe wir werden vielleicht über alle
vorschläge auch die anderen fraktionen
haben übrigens ideen und vorschläge
hören sie ruhig zu vielleicht
interessiert ja haben auch vorschläge
und dann macht es auch sinn gemeinsam
diskutieren zu können und vielleicht
gemeinsam das beste raus machen zu
können und vielleicht vielleicht so
meine antwort noch wenn sie interessiert
ich habe ja mit interesse wahrgenommen
dass sie ihm macht mit mach's nach
mach's besser mit die sie kennen es
vielleicht noch deswegen haben sie es
auch angesprochen gerade zitiert haben
die schule olympiade der ddr die war
interessant sonntags morgens im
fernsehen ich habe es übrigens auch ab
und zu mal gesehen aber von transparenz
war da überhaupt nichts da war gar
nichts das war in transparenter wurde im
hintergrund gekungelt wenn sie wissen
wie es mit abi war also von daher das
jetzt als beispiel zu bringen kann ja
nur der schluss gewesen sein
mach's besser und ihr antrag ich komme
gleich drauf denn der ist ja gegenstand
ist in vielen punkten besser zu machen
aber die logik kann doch nicht sein
jetzt stimmen wir dagegen beziehen es
gar nicht ein sondern diskutieren doch
besser alle vorgelegten anträge
gemeinsam das war die intention so wurde
auch im geschäftsordnungsausschuss
diskutiert und die argumente wenn ihr
antrag so gut ist können sie ja weiter
aufrechterhalten
soweit die antwort und dann kommen wir
doch mal zu dem antrag der fraktion die
linke
da ist ein wesentlicher punkt drin das
ist die genaue ausweisung der einkünfte
gut das scheint ja konsens zu sein das
ist schon mal gut und das zweite das ist
den die berufsgeheimnisträger da der
kollege muss man schon relativ viel
zugesagt dass sie da sehr ungenau in
ihrem antrag sind bestimmte dinge gar
nicht einbeziehen und an
dinge zu tief einbeziehen da werden wir
noch einmal drüber nachdenken müssen
über die berufsgeheimnisträger aber auch
der antrag der fraktion der fdp ist
nicht perfekt der geht über eine
konkrete definition in § 44a
abgeordnetengesetz nicht hinaus da
müssen wir glaube ich deutlich mehr
machen und ich glaube wir können auch an
vielen punkten einen konsens finden denn
wir wollen nebentätigkeiten nicht
gänzlich verbieten
aber wir möchten schon gerne dass das
was wir in den letzten wochen und
monaten erlebt hat nie wieder
stattfindet und dann komme ich zum
antrag auch und zu den ideen der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen sie
vermischen in ihrem antrag immer noch
ich hatte mehrmals gesagt auch zum thema
lobbyregister die themen lobbyregister
legislativen fußabdruck verhaltensregeln
und regeln in dem abgeordnetengesetz und
der geschäftsordnung wir haben gestern
das lobbyregister geregelt das ist gut
so wir regeln heute wir haben die
vorschläge gerade auf den tisch gelegt
burschen die kollegin schnyder hat es
gemacht von heute an die
verhaltensregeln die nebeneinkünfte und
und und ich muss nicht alles wiederholen
was kollege schnyder und kollege dr
badke gesagt haben und wir werden auch
weiter darüber debattieren ob wir einen
legislativen fußabdruck wollen ich hatte
es beim einer rede zum lobbyregister
angesprochen
das wird ein thema sein bei dem wir alle
zusammenarbeiten können aber wenn dann
bitte richtig und nicht nur als
exekutiver fußabdruck nicht nur dann
wenn es in der regierung und im
parlament ist dann müssen wir
grundsätzlich darüber diskutieren und
auch die arbeit schon mit beginn von
koalitionsverhandlungen anfangen lassen
da bin ich gerne bereit dazu ich glaube
das ist auch notwendig ich glaube dass
wir heute mit den ersten vorschlägen
wirklich gute vorschläge gemacht haben
die genaue ausweisung nach euro und cent
das ist konsens habe ich den eindruck
die beteiligung an gesellschaften ist
ein wesentlicher punkt die
anzeigepflichtige einkünfte aus
unternehmensbeteiligungen
die weitergeht als beispielsweise eben
nur aktienoptionen auch bis hin zu
derivaten und anderen erscheinungen wir
wollen ja nicht beim nächsten mal wieder
sagen das haben wir nicht geregelt sie
gehen also deutlich weiter und die
bezahlte lobbytätigkeit wird verboten
werden dass ein guter ansatz und weil es
eben auch von kollegen buschmann erwähnt
worden ist es auch gut dass wir
ehrenamtliche tätigkeit beibehalten
können
denn so haben wir die verbindung in die
gesellschaft die wir auch haben wollen
ein wesentlicher punkt und dann komme
ich auch zum schluss dass es bei
missbrauch auch die möglichkeit
verbotene einnahmen abzuschöpfen
dann bleibt auch nichts mehr und dann
noch als zusatz ein ordnungsgeld zu
bekommen dadurch wird es wirklich
verhindert dass so etwas noch einmal
vorkommt und ich hoffe dass wir in den
beratungen und debatten die sich jetzt
anschließend werden dies im konsens
machen und wenn das sich wiederfindet
was sie in ihrem antrag haben dann
können sie ja sogar zustimmen so hatte
ich sie eben verstanden das haben sie ja
sogar angekündigt die afg wird nicht
zustimmen und das unterscheidet dann
vielleicht auch von der afg ich hoffe
dass die linke würdigsten zustimmt bei
der afg sich da keine hoffnung
dankeschön
patrick sensburg war dass viele unions
fraktion ja der ton ist hier etwas rauer
geworden jan korte hatte sich doch dann
nochmal darüber beschwert denn die
linksfraktion hatte einen gesetzentwurf
und einen antrag hier eingereicht und
beide wurden erst gestern von der
tagesordnung wieder heruntergenommen am
markt bülow spricht jetzt erst
fraktionslos präsidentin werte damen und
herren
ja viele schöne reden die wir hören ich
hätte mir gewünscht bin jetzt 18 jahre
im bundestag von diesen reden mehr
gehört zu haben und ich frag mich wie
glaubwürdig sind diese reden wenn in
diesen 18 jahren nichts passiert ist
wenn alles blockiert worden ist an
anträgen was zum beispiel von grün von
linken gekommen ist wenn jede offensive
jede position immer nur abgelehnt worden
ist und wenn der antrag nicht weit genug
geht denn de erwartet gewinn der bei der
anzahl nicht weit genug stimmen sie doch
heute zu machen dann noch einen besseren
aber es werden sie ja nicht tun sie
könnten heute beweisen wie ehrlich sie
es meinen
es wird aber wieder nicht passieren also
schauen wir uns das doch mal an oder wie
ehrlich ist es denn dieses thema erst
wie glaubwürdig ist es denn dieses thema
auszugraben auch zb ist lobbyregister
nach dem fall am tor und dann wieder in
der versenkung zu verschwinden und jetzt
wird den korruptionsfällen auf einmal
wieder aus der blut zukommt wie
glaubwürdig ist es vor allen dingen wenn
dieser herr am tor platz 1 der
landesliste gesetzt und sozusagen
spitzenkandidat wird wo ist denn dann
die glaubwürdigkeit
also wenn sie regeln schaffen wollen
dann müssen sie die auch anwenden wie
glaubwürdig ist es wir haben gestern
über das lobbyregister gesprochen wenn
da zum beispiel sachen fehlen wie die
finanzierung der lobbyisten und dann
sagt ein unions kollege gestern bei der
debatte ja da können wir ja nicht mit
anfangen bei den ministerien was für
eine bürokratie das ist wenn man alle
auflisten unserer loki termine auf
listen und dann auch noch sagen wir das
finanziert da ist bürokratie zu viel
aber wenn hartz 4 empfänger mit
sanktionen belastet werden und
kontrolliert werden mit einem riesigen
bürokratischen apparat dann ist es
völlig in ordnung wenn es um einiges
geht auch das ist eben nicht glaubwürdig
und wenn man es denn wirklich ernst
meint dann finde ich sollte man
insgesamt eine diskussion führen und ich
glaube das sollte eine
bürgerinnenversammlung tun diese
diskussion zu führen denn wenn man seine
eigenen regeln macht dann ist man immer
befangen
also wenn wir eine
bürgerinnenversammlung brauchen dann zu
diesem thema die vorgaben macht und ich
glaube dann haben wir eine chance
wirklich was hier umzusetzen
über parteigrenzen über fraktionsgrenzen
hinweg weil das ist das nächste problem
wenn es nicht wieder nur um parteitaktik
gehen würde dann würden sie heute dem
antrag zustimmen oder den anderen
anträgen die von den grünen und von
anderen fraktionen gekommen sind aber es
geht wieder nur ein paar takte und
möglichst über den wahlkampf zu kommen
und das ist eben keine glaubwürdigkeit
stimmen sie den anderen anträgen zu
stimmen sie den petitionen es gibt
mittlerweile fünf oder sechs positionen
über 50.000 unterschriften schon haben
die genau zu dem thema sind dann
beschäftigen sie sich mal mit diesen
petitionen und mit diesen gruppen oder
warum haben sie nicht den parteikurs
unterschrieben den ich mit dem kollegen
schickt vor sieben jahren gemacht habe
wenn sie glaubwürdig sein wollen dann
machen sie bei den initiativen mit und
reden hier nicht so schön sondern
handeln endlich vielen dank marco bülow
war das der fraktionslose abgeordnete
der bundestag diskutiert über
transparenz regelungen wir verlassen für
heute das plenum das thema wird
allerdings hier noch häufiger zur
sprache kommen da bin ich ganz sicher